in this video I want to introduce
nitrogen metabolism and nitrogen
fixation so as many of you may or may
not know n2 or nitrogen gas is a very
prevalent gas in our atmosphere it's
about 80 percent of the gas in our
atmosphere and generally speaking it's
not a very reactive gas in addition
gaseous nitrogen is not a usable form of
nitrogen what am i mean by that well us
or us humans need nitrogen for
biological molecules and many other
organisms do as well so specifically
what do we need it for well if you think
about things like amino acids right that
make up proteins they contain nitrogen
which we need right if we want to make
amino acids we need to have nitrogen
around
in addition nucleic acids right we need
to which are made from nucleotides they
have nitrogen in them as well so we need
to have nitrogen in order to make these
biological compounds so how can nitrogen
gas be converted into a usable form
well that process is called nitrogen
fixation so nitrogen fixation requires
two things those two things are energy
and electrons so there are two ways in
which nitrogen nitrogen can be fixed so
the first way is lightning which
basically provides both right the energy
and the electrons for nitrogen fixation
but not your message and fixation by
lightning it's not really too relevant
for us what's more relevant is nitrogen
fixing bacteria nitrogen fixing bacteria
so these things are pretty important
where are these nitrogen fixing bacteria
they exist in the roots of leguminous
plants
so things like soy beans and peanuts and
peas in the roots of those plants there
are these bacteria so the bacteria and
the plant have a symbiotic relationship
so and they both benefit from the
relationship together so the plants what
they get is they get a reduced form of
nitrogen which is a useable form of
nitrogen specifically that useable form
of nitrogen is ammonium ion okay so the
plant benefits in that it gets a reduced
and usable form of nitrogen from
bacteria which is ammonium the bacteria
what they get is they get ATP right
which provides energy for the production
of the usable nitrogen because this
process is highly undergone a curb
requires energy so the bacteria gets ATP
from the plant and then the plant
benefits in that it gets the ammonium
from the bacteria so they both they both
benefit from this relationship so how
does the actual nitrogen fixation though
hatch how does that actually happen so
there's this complex of enzymes called
the nitrogenous complex of the
nitrogenous complex simply does is it
takes gaseous nitrogen and turns it into
ammonium ion so initially we have a gas
as a nitrogen and that of course has one
two three four five pairs of electrons
for total of 10 electrons we're gonna do
in this process is we want to create two
ammonium x' so we're going to add six
electrons and eight protons right six
electrons because each of these ammonium
have eight electrons total so this is
going to be a total of 16 electrons of
course and each ammonium has four
hydrogen on it so those come from eight
protons so that's basically what the
nitrogenous complex does it is it turns
this this unusable form of nitrogen
turns it into a usable form of nitrogen
this ammonium here we'll talk in a later
video exactly about how it is usable but
for now this is what I wanted to get at
the overall reaction essentially what
we're going to do is we actually take
eight electrons and add them to the
gaseous nitrogen and this process cost
16 ATP which is actually pretty crazy
when we keep actually the great color
going here so we have 16 ATP which of
course is uh turn it into 16 ATP and 16
inorganic phosphates these of course
came from the plant right now we added
10 protons and that might not make sense
just yet right adding 8 electrons and 10
protons because over here we set 6
electrons and eight protons but we will
see what I mean in just a second and of
course we've created those two ammonium
which are now usable but we also created
a hydrogen gas right so this hydrogen
gas used up two protons and two
electrons so the extra two electrons
from here and the two extra protons here
we're used to make a hydrogen gas so now
this ammonium can now be used for the
synthesis synthesis of amino acids which
can be used for proteins and of course
nucleotides which can be used for
production of nucleic acids like DNA in
RNA I hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching one last thing I'd like
to mention is that I'm a tutor if you
live in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email iMovie university
at gmail.com and check out the
description below for a little bit more
information thanks for watching